allowance very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that now Germany
has a relatively new government
Chancellor Angela Merkel's third but
what about the opposition well it's made
up of two parties one of which is the
greens and my guest today is one of the
leading figures in the green party here
he is in person Boris papa thank you
very much for coming all the way to
Berlin today great stuff fantastic now
Boris Palmer is elegant and eloquent and
he has for several years now been the
dynamic influential and sometimes
controversial mayor of the southwestern
city of tubigon so we have a lot to talk
about but Boris Palmer the Honorable
mayor of tubigon my viewers out there
will be wondering why I'm telling them
that you are elegant and eloquent and
you're shady yeah what is he telling it
at this yeah you must admit that you do
like wearing elegant and slick suits no
I don't have to admit that but it's a
proven fact sir yeah to the opposite and
actually for a very long time all my
friends said that I have no knowledge of
fashion at all uh-huh but there was it
was clearly a change because you were
listing a heritage in the German in the
german edition of GQ magazine very
recently right as one of the best
dressed men in germany yeah it's a joke
really i think it's not sure still they
have chosen me to be one of the best
dressed man in germany and of course
being a mayor i had to change some
things I some suits amortize a very
important events only very important
events and somehow I have managed to
dress a way that they like okay what did
you what your other green colleagues say
about this because the Greens have got
an image especially internationally
right of wearing sort of woollen
pullovers and having tousled long hair
and birkenstocks at all this that's a
long time ago long time ago there's only
a picture that you can recreate because
it's 20 years ago at least okay you are
the mayor to go on to more serious stuff
you are the mayor
of the southwestern city of tubigon I've
been in Germany an awful long time and
I'm very well traveled in Germany but I
have to admit that I've never ever been
to tubing and and many of our viewers
won't have been there I should come I
should go yeah I know I do tell me why
especially because it's a wonderful
atmosphere all the young people
University a very dynamic atmosphere so
you have people all around the squares
and the streets and also we have that
wonderful medieval town that has not
been hit during World War two I am and
for that reason it's also really German
ok it's a special place it's a very
german place and you are the mayor I
need before we get going a little bit i
need one or two facts from you yeah how
many green mayor's are there in Germany
Germany I guess there should be about a
dozen that doesn't about a dozen and in
our state there are three that's why
blocked should cut into me mmm that's
interesting and so if there are a dozen
mayor's that's a number but it's not
really very many how many how many
mayors are there throughout Germany but
any idea I guess I'm 10,000 some 10,000
yeah yeah so it's a race a drop in the
ocean a little bit but it's influential
it's important isn't it yeah okay and
one last point that we need to establish
when you were when you were first
elected mayor what percentage of the
vote did you get 50.4 was a really close
margin yeah but on the other hand the
second best only told 30.5 percent so I
had twenty percent more than her
you clearly are young you have no fear
of heights no audible I do yeah you
wouldn't get me up one of those chimneys
I'm quite brave I mean I go walking in
the mountains and all that kind of thing
but I would not go I wanted to invite
you to visit our church because there's
a wonderful few from you have to climb
up the outside of it or what no inside
okay I'll go up it when I come to too
big and I'll go up the church am talking
of to begin when you were 11 years old
you were out there working on the market
that's right your dad yeah right was
that a tough experience or a character
forming experience or both both I guess
yeah it was tough but it was fun as well
hmm and actually at this age I already
had a few of the Town Hall because the
market place of course is exactly
located where the Town Hall is I sold to
people sell it and strawberries watching
the town hall at the age of 10 and now
you're going to tell me that you used to
look up at the town hall and think I as
a green politician we're going to be the
Miller of two no I didn't think that
you'd invite my father tried to get
inside and become the mayor at that time
already exactly your father I knew what
it was all about I mean we were laughing
because of that ur the the episode with
your father helmet call Helmut Schmidt
helmet Palmer yay was clearly a
character yes of course uh and my
impression was I have to say very often
these days when people in politics get
angry people say that's totally
unacceptable you shouldn't be getting
angry about things you should be very
rational your father was clearly an
angry activist why was he so angry it
was a rebel so he had a Jewish father
and she realized that all the odd
fascists that all the old Nazis were
back to power in the 50s and there was
the starting of his political activism
and he did something that was
unprecedented he started to stand for
the mayor's office in almost any city in
the near neighborhoods so he tried that
in 250 cities and became very famous
because of that yeah and also in some
time some cases he tried to really win
the race but in many cases he knew he
didn't have a chance and for that reason
pushed forward ideas and there was
something that was really special to him
and made him famous in the state it's an
interesting fact that you just mentioned
about his father who in turn is clearly
your grandfather right what was his
story then well he had to leave the
country in 1938 and he died in the
United States in the 50s really yeah hmm
what's a sad sad tale um so my father
never knew him your father resumen you
never knew him as no of course not no
tell me about him about your father's
relationship to you do he died in 2004
yeah and he saw what you had become a
what you had begin to become did he see
that as a continuation of his activism
or did he see it as something different
now actually it was even more than a
continuation he told people when I had
been elected for the first time to be a
member of the baden-württemberg state
parliament that he now had his personal
member of parliament great stuff yeah
but before you became elected to
Parliament you had joined the Green
Party yeah already yeah in 1996 okay so
relatively early days yeah well what was
it about the Green Party that attracted
you simply one idea to protect the
environment to protect the environment
yes no and what did you see at that time
as the threat to the environment I read
the report to the Club of Rome I have
borders of growth mm-hmm the limits of
growth and that totally convinced me so
I really start to share with our viewers
a little bit about what that what that
was all about right I really started
with politics with the idea that we are
over stretching over stretching the
natural resources so that we will
exploit the planet that we ruin the
planet and that we might see the end of
our civilization within a century mmm
and that of course I wanted to prevent
that from happening mm-hmm okay that's a
pretty dirt that's a pretty dramatic
sort of vision that you had of well how
the future could evolve does it
things got better or worse since then
both unfortunately both on the one hand
we see that we can adapt to the problems
much better than they thought 40 years
ago on the other side we don't use the
time we gained to improve but we were
some things for example carbon dioxide
emissions have doubled within 15 years
and they will double within the next 15
or 20 years and that will certainly end
in dramatic problems globally mm-hmm
people look to Germany when when they
hear for people like you saying what
you've just said people look to Germany
is one of the countries that might help
to find solutions to the problems we
face people look to Germany and view
Germany as a green country that's been a
long tradition when I go abroad and
people and I come from Germany people
always say to me tell me about green
Germany but I wonder to an extent is
Germany at this point in time would you
go would you describe Germany as a green
countries that a fair description no but
compare dunno no but now compared to
most other countries we are greener and
that is to be in a leading position and
I think that we need such role models
what we call in a given day so the
switch from fossil and nuclear to
renewables that is something that could
be a blueprint and that we could use
worldwide to get rid of that old fashion
model of Industry and I think that is
very important hmm if you're going to
make these changes will talk about the
energy vendor this this massive
transition is revolutionary try a
transition here in Germany in in in a
couple of minutes but if you're going to
change things if you got to change
things here in Germany if you guys
change things anywhere in the world you
need to get you need to be in power and
there's sometimes been a reluctance on
the part of the Greens to to strive for
power to be in power how does it feel to
you to actually exercise power how
comfortable are you about that I am very
comfortable because it is a great
position in our Constitution the mayor
has options in almost any fields so
communities are very strong in Germany
and therefore you have many fields of
influence but I don't agree with you
that only if you are in power you can
change things because
if you think about Germany's decision to
stop nuclear the use of nuclear power
that happened when the green actually
were in the opposition true so sometimes
a good idea that you push forward is
realized by others and that's as good as
well hmm so it's a balance between what
actually comes out of the the bottom end
in politics is a balance between
activism outside power and power at
robotics okay
before we talk about tubing and
specifically I'd like to talk about
something that you just mentioned in
passing a wee little bit just because
because it's very interesting in the way
that Germany compares with other
countries you said that you as a mayor
of what is a relatively a medium-sized
town you have real power you have real
prerogatives can you describe sure what
you can do you know what you can realize
especially in the southwest of Germany
for a very very long time at least 200
years mayor's have been very powerful so
I am elected directly by the people that
is a part of my power because I have
that support yeah and I am the head of
the administration so every single
public official is in my lead and these
are 2,500 people in the city of
tuebingen also i am the head of the
boards of the local companies like the
power utility okay and we have a housing
utility and the whole thing together is
a budget of about 500 million euros per
year that substantive that's a lot
that's a lot that's a big company yeah
and I'm also the head of council so I'm
the first representative of the town and
also the head of the administration and
these two positions together in one
person that makes the position really
powerful that's interesting well when we
talk about the greens into began by
impression because we got some real
insights into how there's green sort of
perceive themselves and how they live in
tubigon my impression is that greens are
people who are well off have a good
income well situated and like to spend
an awful lot of time with other greens
well there is some truth in that uh-huh
there is some truth in that but it's not
totally correct yeah so I would describe
it a little bit different I believe that
what you said is true but on the other
hand people who tend to vote green are
very careful about their neighborhood so
they care about the people that are less
well-off and they want politics
ditions to look after these people and
also they care about the neighborhood as
a whole they tried to engage themselves
and they care about the environment so
it's really people who are careful and
not only people who look after their own
life I think that is the point so what
does all that add up to when people are
careful about their their environment
because I know an awful lot of people
tend to look at the greens and say they
are people who say look if everybody was
just more like me the world would be a
better place but that doesn't work does
it and it's not true even because the
greens tends to earn more money and for
that reason they spend more money and
spending money is normally connected to
some kind of use of energy and resources
yeah and deploying natural resources so
of course that is not sure but on the
other hand I think that people who try
to live in a way that could be it could
be copied that could be some useful that
used as a model on the planet that those
people are somehow aware of the problems
we face yeah in the present and I
believe that is a good notion that is a
good habit of course you should not be
idle about that yeah so there's an
important pioneering function there it
away in society that the Greens have had
for many many years I think so yeah
greens have changed Germany being
pioneers okay and that that district
that we were looking at in that report
just now that I I don't know what that
area of tubing and might be called but
it is that the kind of area that you
live in to bigger do you happen to live
there the district that we were just had
your ceiling and actually I used to live
there is you've got the point yeah but I
have moved to the city center now I see
ya because it's interesting for me as I
say I've never been to tubing him but I
but I not far away from tubing and
you've mentioned it already one of the
other cities that's got a green marriage
freiburg yeah and it's a lovely mullen
very similar yes same kind of sort of
sociology of you sir william and that
there's a district in freiburg that i
went and had a really good look at
called the verb and district which is
very similar to what we've just been
seeing into begonia great it's all sort
of Greek it's green it's quite literally
green and it's friendly and there's lots
of smiling people and what have you I
the feeling though that there was a
really strong high level of sort of
social control Petra is that a good
thing or a bad thing actually I think
that we lost social control in cities is
part of a problem and I believe that
it's good if people look after each
other so for that reason I don't think
that's conservative or old-fashioned I
believe that's much better than letting
people just live the way they live
without thinking what their problems are
so it i think you have really to look
after each other and cities are places
where that works better than in the
rural district we are talking about is
creating and living in something called
society yeah and it's very interesting
because in Germany people still talk
about society as though it's a very real
and desirable thing and in the
anglo-saxon world Margaret Thatcher said
you know there is no such thing as
society there was a living what we want
to be I don't know what shoppers
consumers I'm sure there is such a thing
yeah um Boris Palmer I wrote down here
yeah is a politician who advocates the
preservation of the best things in
society and opposes radical changes no
not bad not be are good good so it's a
fair definition of you because it's
pretty much the classical definition of
a conservative with a small see as we
say in English I'm certainly a
conservative green and the Greens in my
state are more conservative than in all
the other states and I don't think that
it's bad being conservative especially
protecting environment is something that
is conservative at all yeah so nothing
else than that but the Conservatives in
Germany in the 70s or 80s had forgotten
that idea yeah and they thought that
growth and wealth is is much more
important than protecting the
environment for that reason there has
been a new party and many who founded
the Greens used to be conservative of
course the majority party is a left-wing
party
okay so we've got a party where the
majority of the people in the party are
left of center in the spectrum which way
you're saying but nevertheless people
are talking and I mean we've just had an
election in job we've got a new
government but nevertheless people are
talking an awful lot about the future of
this country being a future with her
with a Conservative government in
coalition with the greens is that
something you want and is that something
you believe would be good for Germany
yes I think it would be good for Germany
because we would combine two ideas the
idea of an industrial country that is
what the Christian Democrats stand for
hmm they are the party with the biggest
support is a management and Angela
Merkel's conservatives the Christian
Democrats is right and on the other hand
there is the idea of the ecological
transformation of that industry and of
society and I think those two ideas
combined would be good for Germany and I
hope that it will happen someday it's
what the political commentators like to
call a marriage made in heaven ABS
that's what Boris but Palmer appears to
think
yeah we were just nodding to each other
about the Japanese connection will talk
about that in just a second let's talk
about those Ellis Mladic first you
you've met her yeah yes I met her a few
times and I met her husband regularly
because we are in the board of a company
that is promoting renewable energies mm
hmm that's interesting ma'am well tell
me a little bit more about deciding what
makes her so brave smuggling things into
the White House and all this I think
it's the vision hmm and it's the way she
talks to people so she's really
encouraging everybody it's just a
wonderful person one of those people
she's a wonderful person little bit like
your dad yeah it's very different little
bit okay the way she motivates people is
different okay we've got to talk about
two events big events yeah how old were
you at the time of Chernobyl 14 and how
did you respond what can you remember
that yes of course I read articles
newspapers and a few days later in
school my teacher asked me to share my
knowledge with the class huh yeah and
well of course I told them in about 15
minutes what it was all about what the
problem was yeah why nuclear power was
not responsible and how we could protect
ourselves from the nuclear at fault ok
so that's chanapa yeah yeah many years
later Fukushima now what did that mean
to you Fukushima was the turning point
in Germany's energy policy and everybody
realized we can't go on anymore so it
was really a period when I thought now
it's it's really starting now we have to
start to change everything did you think
that on that day when we was a terrible
i was in a newsroom and i was watching
you know the tidal wave coming all this
kind of stuff yeah and you were thinking
that already i was thinking that because
that was proof that even in Japan which
is as modern as Germany's it could
happen you know and until that day
everybody thought many people who argued
for nuclear power thought that could
only happen in Russia and other states
that are almost failing but now it
happened in Japan so if it happens in
Japan it can have
we were and one thing that people often
say in modern politics is that there's
no leadership like there used to be in
the good old days whenever the good old
days were and in Germany it says it's
something you hear very often as well we
don't have proper leadership despite the
fact that Angela Merkel internationally
as viewed as quite as a sort of a
substantial leader she was certainly a
leader on this one I mean she said
pretty much overnight that's that's it
absolutely yeah the number is up with
with with new nuclear energy did did you
admire her for that or did you were sort
of thick grit your teeth and think she's
stealing our policy oh no no no not at
all no that would be stupid if you
accuse people to steal your policy and
you want to keep bad circumstances just
for the sake of better loadings I think
that's no you no good no I was really
happy about that decision and I was more
thinking about what can we make out of
that now for example in the town and i
have to tell you we had created a few
years before we had created a green
electricity offered to our customers in
the city from the locally owned power
utility yeah and within eight weeks we
almost doubled the number of people who
wanted those contracts so it was good to
have the offer and most good to campaign
for that and we even made money out of
that idea of theme of green ideas it's
interesting what you're saying and
obviously that's important that's
relevant and that significant it's real
but if we've agreed that Germany is a
green country why are your party called
the Greens somewhere down sort of south
of ten percent because of mistakes and
we could be much better two years ago we
pulled some twenty percent and I believe
that we did have a chance to stay up
there but unfortunately parts of my
party the left-wing people in the party
really thought that's a threat because
that would change the party that would
reduce their power within the party yeah
because other people would come in and
for that reason they have formed a
program in the 2013 election that really
appalled many people and that reduced
our results okay
there's one thing we need to talk about
before we before we move on and you've
mentioned it already this this big long
German worth the energy vendor yeah it's
very difficult to sort of translate into
English yeah but it's a massive and
ambitious reform project introduced by
the government to move away from nuclear
energy and fossil fuels towards
renewable energy sources brilliant
definition whoa yeah good I'm happy
about that I'm blows oh well yeah um
it's been called Germany's green gamble
in some of the international media
you're nodding it is a gamble yeah is it
going to work because it's important
we've heard in that report we that's
where we started just now this book it's
important for people in German it's
important for people in Japan because
they'll be looking very closely can the
can these Germans crack it no it could
work economically and technically what
we don't know is whether it will work
politically so that is really crucial
point because it's going to make energy
more expensive and people are going to
have to pay more for energy that's
economically and I believe that can be
solved soundly now the problem is
whether we create a framework where the
new technologies the renewables can work
and at the moment it's fraud it by many
interests especially from big companies
that are still living in the old world
and if you have the wrong framework even
that project could fail so it really is
a gamble but it's a political question
it's not a technical question and it's
not an economic question
most streets here in the German capital
Berlin where I live yeah our 30
kilometer they've got a 30 kilometer an
hour limit on them most and in fact
three quarters according to the report
yeah and my guess is that you would want
to see all streets taba 30 limit is that
right in the long run yes I believe that
it's better in cities especially where
people live I do think that some
highways of course can have a higher
speed limit but where people live 30 is
the right when you talk about babe
that's where people live it it what's
your main argument are you arguing
emissions or are you arguing noise or ii
arguing safety or all of them mmm do you
understand that the car industry which
is so very very important here in
Germany doesn't share your enthusiasm
for this project well they don't need to
be enthusiastic but on the other hand
the average speed in cities is about 20
or 25 kilometers anyway so the speed
limit doesn't really would use the real
speed in town it's just what you feel it
is like I don't think that is so
important mm-hmm it's very pragmatic
really the solution that you're offering
is very so realistic i think i'm sure
you would say do you mean you come from
a part of the world baden-württemberg
where cars are very much a part of sort
of people's lives and people's work what
one thing that I personally I must say
I'm often disappointed by the fact that
I you know like every normal person I
watch my evening news and there a car
shows where all the big German
manufacturers they put out green cars
they drive onto the stage and there's a
fanfare and all this kind of stuff and
they tell me that at some stage this is
going to go to market or change my life
or something it never happens yeah why
is that well it's still difficult
there's a lot of technology to be
invented it's expensive and other reason
these cars exists but only very few are
sold I think that's going to change and
I think it's important for the German
car industry to be ahead of others so
they need to be greener than a dress to
sell their products in 10 or 15 years do
you these guys are there round the
corner from where you are there in
which is just up the road or wherever
yeah do you actually because you mean
you're influential you're an important
player in Barton Barton bag do you
actually meet with them to use of course
I to I and talk to them yes they invited
me several times and they wanted to know
my views on their products and I think
that's a good thing because customers
like me who are interested in
ecologically sound products will become
more that's what I'm really sure about
and you come you come away thinking that
they haven't sort of you sold your story
you think you have changes is just
around the corner I think that what is
that change could I look like I've been
I suppose that's the question we're
running out of time but I'd really like
to know what you know you will relate
future looks like you will see cars that
are much more energy efficient than
those that are on the road much more
energy efficient yeah yeah how do you
get around the country these days you
don't have a car I don't have a car
normally by plane if it's a long
distance and by a train if it's a
shorter distance by bike if it's in the
city mmm the Greens have been in power
the Greens have actually been in power
in central government here in Germany
and have been very influential around
the country and have a pioneering role
in the in the in the debate around
transport policy I personally have been
disappointed about how you talk about
the railway system in Germany its
continued to get more and more and more
expensive in its and in its a system
that is there to sort of make money
possibly go stock market I don't know
what I'm always disappointed about that
well I don't get something done for me
I'm disappointed about that as well but
we never had a German transportation
minister from the greens uh I'd like to
see that well yeah I like it very
interesting exercise yeah okay we
normally have a quiz at the end of the
show yeah quick questions quick answers
yeah mmm are you a rebel or an
establishment man both both yeah the
situation okay we talked about your look
at the beginning of the show ok do you
prefer a business suit of cycling lycra
cycling oh you're gonna say that yeah
principles or compromises both you can't
have one there's a compromise we're
gonna leave it there I'm getting a side
yeah that's your lot with the eloquent
and elegant Boris Palmer there's more
talking to Emily including my blog and
our archived on the website and you
might also like to watch the German
version of the show to be storage with
the io Schumacher for now just bye bye
come back next week
you